happy day four of vlogmas with me
iJustine today's product is the insta
360 4K webcam I did a review on this
earlier this year and you guys actually
were really into this so I'm so excited
that insta360 gave us one of these to
give away to you guys it's so fun it's
like a webcam but it's an AI webcam like
it'll follow you around the room it has
this really cool whiteboard feature that
was one of my favorite features I don't
know it's like the future it's such a
simple piece of tech but it's so super
fun for some bonus entries you can
follow insta360 on Twitter and for all
of the ways to win and how to get more
entries check out ijustine.com vlogmas
see you there